My cancer markers have slightly come down. The tumors in my left breast are smaller,
but the tumors in my right breast seem larger. The right breast has a tumor wound and had a biopsy.
What are your thoughts? The tumor wound, sorry, and had a biopsy. What are your thoughts?
Well, I don't know. The tumor, the right breast might be more inflamed right now, so that might not
be a bad thing, that it seems larger. It might be because your immune system really needs to
address that and kill that, and it's really because of the inflammation cause for the immune response.
I don't know that for a surgeon, but I would go with that thought. If you had a biopsy there,
you have a tumor wound, well then you're going to have scar tissue that's never going to go away,
and it doesn't need to go away either, so I wouldn't necessarily worry about that.
That's scar tissue, it's just my body, and it's not cancerous.